mire toda esta tierra y está
completamente invadida por las langostas
se lo comen todo
para gisef es una pesadilla miles de
langostas devastaron sus tierras su
granja de cabras es una de las 500
actividades económicas que se han visto
afectadas por la invasión de estos
insectos en cerdeña
Pues esta situación nos obliga a gastar
más en comida para alimentar a las
cabras y cuando usamos insecticidas en
la tierra tenemos que mantener a los
animales dentro por dos semanas el
impacto es colosal para toda la región
50.000 hectáreas de tierra están en
peligro y daños que podrían ascender a
20 millones de euros frente a esta
amenaza un equipo de 200 agentes
especializados dan seguimiento a las
langostas mire este punto rojo de aquí
significa que hay un foco activo de
langostas uno de nuestros equipos
desplegados para realizar inspecciones
encontró algunos insectos muy jóvenes Y
entonces ese mismo día o por mucho el
día siguiente enviamos un equipo para
llevar a cabo el tratamiento en las
últimas semanas se han realizado más de
3000 tratamientos con insecticidas en 28
municipios de la región pero no es
suficiente para tranquilizar a los
consejos locales que no pueden ocultar
su impotencia por este fenómeno el
fenómeno fruto esta situación es
resultado del cambio climático es
preocupante no tengo los para hacer
frente a lo que está pasando mi
administración tiene que gestionar las
quejas de los agricultores que le exigen
una solución al gobierno
de parte de la institución Se declaró
una catástrofe natural y el gobierno
prometió indemnizaciones una solución a
corto plazo hasta que se pueda erradicar
la Plaga de langostas y así proteger la
agricultura